welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy who's
gonna be keeping you on track for the
next ten weeks with snowpiercer
the show has just dropped its first
episode and throughout this video we're
going to be discussing its overall plot
ending and more there will be heavy
spoilers here and so if you haven't had
a chance to check it out yet and I
highly recommend that you turn off now
if you still aboard then please
subscribe to the channel as we're going
to be breaking down the series week by
week and you definitely don't want to
miss what's next without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of snowpiercer episode 1
after the effects of global warming
devastate the planet scientists try and
cool down the earth but in doing so they
instead doom the population in an
attempt to save what he can inventor mr.
Wilford built a train 1001 cause long to
way out the thawing of the earth if
you've seen the movie you'll pretty much
be up to speed with everything already
and similar to that film we start off in
the lower class cars which contain the
poverty-stricken members of society the
talese are crammed into carriages red
crushed insects sterilized and stamped
on every time they try and rise up
seventy percent of the population
actually exists in third in the tale and
their inequality is vastly shown by the
lavish life that the front lead this
fuels their need to fight back and it
looks like the series will be focused
primarily on two storylines
a murder investigation in the front end
of the Train and a revolution in the
tale Revolution is an important term and
snowpiercer as it not only means to
revolt but it also carries meaning for
the trains journey itself every time the
Train circles the world it's classed as
a revolution and therefore it carries a
double meaning we actually pick up right
at the beginning of the lower-class
boarding the Train and are introduced to
Andre Layton Zahra and miles security
try and stop the incoming threat and the
leader of them commander gray is sliced
across the cheek which leaves a scar
that we still see him bearing later in
the episode after a time jump we see
that Layton and Zahra have split up and
the latter has been moved forward in the
tale though we don't know why this was
it is important to know that they bore
the train together and were in a
relationship beforehand they knew each
other's families so you could say it was
getting pretty serious now
now Zara wanted to die with a family but
Layton promised her a good life on the
train which we know turned out to be
untrue she likely became disenfranchised
with the life in the tail and bargained
her way out of there since then she's
not formed any real meaningful
relationships and has drifted about with
different groups likely being in a
similar situation to what she had in the
tail Zara is the one that informs the
front that Leighton as a policeman and
the two cross paths later on in the
episode Layton has become a parental
figure for miles who has grown up and
with his quote/unquote trained mum Josie
they've started a family similar to the
film the talese are fed protein blocks
which we learned in the movie adaptation
were made out of insects it very much
carries the meaning you are what you eat
and thus you get the feeling that the
tale ease of considered bugs were also
introduced to Melanie kaval played by
Jennifer Connelly by the end of the
episode she's revealed to be Wilfred but
whether she actually is owner is a point
of contention she sort of introduces the
main players up front and we meet Ruth
the Folgers and their bodyguard the
Folgers are actually extremely rich
people that finance the creation of the
Train and they were the ones that
provided Welford with the money they've
likely met him before and thus they
would know whether Melanie was the
character or not on IMDB Sean Bean is
listed as welford as well and thus we
can take from this that he is really
playing the character so Melanie likely
hasn't held captive or has killed him in
order to take his place if this is the
case then it would carry forth the
revolution aesthetic that the show is
laced with and she would have ousted the
head of authority in the front in order
to control the train similar to how the
Talese wished you now from the off the
season really recaptures the atmosphere
of the film and it's easy to see why
with a lot of the creative team coming
across from it boon jang-ho is a
producer and the set design is extremely
similar however that doesn't mean that
snowpiercer is merely copying the film
whether it's going to tie in fully or
not we don't know yet but it does look
like we're gonna have some surprises the
series has a great cast and also some
real formal
faces that I wasn't expecting to see
when they showed up it got me really on
board excuse the pun and each actor
really brings their all here
shout outs hector salamanca and trevor
of course within the first 10 minutes
the tallies are already planning their
revolt due to the first-class starving
and sterilizing them in the film we
learned that in order to keep the
population at a certain level Wilford
would starve sterilized and occasionally
allow an uprising to happen in order to
kill off masses of the populace he did
this through an insider in the tale
known as Gilliam but here it doesn't
really seem like there's someone working
for him but I guess we will find out
what the talese do suspect is that
leighton may have filled this role after
he's called forth to investigate a
murder within first this is carried out
by ruth who dons a fur coat when making
her announcement similar to how minister
mason did in the film also I'm sure Ruth
is played by the same actress as the
casting woman in Hollywood so yeah maybe
she got this role because she's good at
standing in front of people and making
announcements anyway
what this does is that it shows that the
tale is far colder than the front and
that they have it really bad there this
lip service paid to another revolution
and the removal of arms which as we saw
from the film was a punishment when the
tally stood up to Authority
Leighton is put through sanitation which
brought up images of concentration camps
for me and he's escorted by the brakeman
leighton gets to see the son for the
first time in a long time and we also
see the length of the train as he's put
into the mess hall here he meets roche
who informs him of the body of sean wise
who's been cut up and dumped into a
hidden compartment we learned that he
was sleeping with Zahra aka Layton's
partner before the Train Zahra was in a
relationship with three people and those
in a car tend to be polygamists this is
called a chain and it's what you got to
do if you want to run train lane is also
introduced to a former Detroit police
officer called Beth who beats him up and
it's clearly very prejudiced towards him
even though before all of this he would
have actually been her superior a
similar crime happened years prior and a
person was convicted for it which means
that there's either a copycat wilford
jail the wrong person this convict is
Nicky Jay who we learn has been under
suspension for two years on snowpiercer
this is care
by putting people in a draw and slowly
injecting them with kronole a drug that
causes hallucinations if you've seen the
film then you'll know that chronal has
been modified into a street drug and we
spent a lot of time in the movie with
namgoong who was an addict it's also
capable of being used as an explosive so
you can't expect it to play a big part
throughout the season Layton is taken
back to Zara and he also goes through a
green house car that carries a
similarity to the Garden of Eden here
Melanie picks a strawberry and though
it's not an apple which was used in the
Bible that fruit carries a similar
meaning with it
Melanie is a God she possesses all the
knowledge and power here and Layton is
subservient to her however he wants to
break free and gain what she has similar
to Adam and Eve
Melanie picked the fruit first similar
to how Eve picked the fruit first and
Layton could also be viewed as a
stand-in for Adam the film ended on an
Adam and Eve aesthetic and the season
may end up with the two coming together
especially if Wilfred is God we also see
a class trip taking place there and the
teacher is indoctrinating the children
to the message of Wilfred in the movie
the teacher hammered home that life
outside the Train instantly meant death
but we did learn throughout that things
had begun to endure and it was possible
to exist outside up top in the aquarium
car we joined Jinju who meets with
Melanie jin-joo is seemingly in a
relationship with someone and though I
have seen some say that it may be
Melanie I think due to Melanie asking
who this could be it is in the case they
talk about other work continuing and
this may be a reference to how she has
taken the roles and responsibilities of
Wilfred what she does isn't too clear
yet but due to her position of the car
she's clearly very wealthy the way that
the train works is that the further up
you are the more powerful that you are
and thus we can take from this that
she's a very important individual back
in the tail it Seaborn's birthday and he
asks for a rack man enough recording
rack man enough actually died four days
before his 70th birthday and this is
sort of echoed here Yvonne commits
suicide and as the trains eldest member
this sends the talese into a meltdown
they get the security guards to come and
collect his body and they rush the
brakeman and gods
a character named strong boy who is a
mute Russia's up top and he's joined by
the homie Trevor from GTA it's here that
we see the return of gray the
high-ranking officer from the
introduction a melody recruits a
Leighton to calm the situation down
leighton has given three minutes to
complete the task of stopping the
revolution and in numerology 3 means
completion creation and in the Bible
it's often a sign of divinity something
that Layton represents and that's the
biggest reach in the video
Layton diffuses the situation and saves
Beth by knocking her out this may make
her realize that her prejudice towards
him was wrong but we'll see as we get
further into the series Layton convinces
the group to surrender and thus they're
sent in a suspension in a draw Layton is
planning on using them and reserved for
when the revolution actually happens and
now the attempt has been diffused in
this first episode the season will
likely still head towards it the episode
ends with Melanie going to the engine
room which is actually revealed to be a
dormitory so unlike the film the engine
is actually a ruse and therefore it may
not be contained within a room it said
through our both the show and film that
if you control the engine then you
control a train and this metaphor of
Melanie's quarters being called the
engine could hold a double meaning here
we see images of Melanie's family and it
seems like she has a daughter which is
why I believe that she's not really well
furred Ruth also says something about
Wilfred demanding swift justice
so is possible that she also has had an
interaction with him before that Melanie
would be unable to fake however she does
have a hoodie that says MIT on it which
is a technology college so perhaps she
is indeed who she says she is
Melanie plans out strategies on a chess
board and there's a red line around her
apartment this is similar to the tracks
that we see in the introduction
circulate in the world she goes up to
the car and meets the driver who
addresses her as mr. Wilfred again I'm
sort of torn on this as I think Wilfred
was such a famous character in the world
that many would know of him before the
environment collapsed in addition to
this so we know that Sean Bean is cast
as the character so I do fall under the
impression that Melanie is either
working for him or has taken charge of
the train causing her own revolution
that is um
the rest of the passengers beyond the
driver either way what a cracking way to
start the show and I really enjoyed the
first episode it's got a brilliant
balance of mystery the revolution that
was laced throughout the film and
there's a lot of things to be excited
for going forward obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the premiere and
what you thought of the twists comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this and please drop a thumbs up and
make sure you stay locked to the channel
for breakdowns on the show as it
progresses if you want something else to
watch and to maybe get some clues and
where things are going make sure you
check out our breakdown of the film
which is gonna be linked at the end we
go over everything you need to know so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you need a quick catch up if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content too
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at Definition
white tea or click this code link in the
description below
every month we give away free movies to
people are subscribed to the channel and
this Monty can win the Marvel phase
three part two boxer and all you have to
do is comment on a video and make sure
you sub with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of June so best of
luck to everyone who takes part
[Music]
you
[Music]